how do i look
exceptionally ordinary some actors just
desperately care about their character's
appearance and some just really want to
break stereotypes whatever it may be it
always seems like the best choice in the
end we've dug into the smallest places
to find some of the best moments an
actor drastically changed their
appearances for films and tv shows side
note we're covering a lot of harry
potter throughout time to play dress-up
with our favorite characters
number one jason isaacs played one of
the most vile harry potter characters
and his initial wardrobe idea didn't
really reflect that
the original concept was to have lucius
malfoy dressed in a pinstripe suit and
have black and white short hair doesn't
really scream evil but luckily he spoke
up to director chris columbus there's no
way he would cut his hair like a muggle
or dress like a muggle he demanded his
character wear a straight black costume
with long white hair this combo became
iconic throughout all eight films but
isaac's demands were not yet finished on
top of the initial changes he asked for
a cane to show the characters power and
wealth
the snake on top with a pull out wand
well we think that was just good
research on his end
number two next up is one of our
favorite witches from the harry potter
franchise bellatrix lestrange the awful
estranged cousin of sirius black made
serious changes to her dress
i also had great fun creating the look
of her helen up on m carter was least to
say unenthusiastic about the outfit she
was given she wanted bellatrix to have a
glamorous aspect to her while still
reflecting her time in azkaban there's a
dilapidated quality to her in the way
that she was once intensely glamorous
costume designer janie tamine agreed
with carter and agreed that she was born
to be in a corset that's about the only
thing we can agree on from bellatrix
number three we're taking a small break
from the wizarding world and jumping
into some marvel heroes starting it off
with elizabeth olsen the powerful
scarlet witch
[Music]
most of the actors in the mcu were not
thrilled with their outfits but at least
they got to cover up olson always had an
issue with being the most outfit
revealing character on the team for one
division she got to make the choice of
how her outfit looked and took full
advantage in covering up but it really
helped with moving around the action
sequences i totally fell
[Music]
number four i am not wearing this helmet
we were shocked to see robert downey jr
drop this burn on his iron man costume
hey robert would you mind putting on
that helmet no yes no downey's opinion
about his helmet started from the very
moment he put it on having a real helmet
and suit proved to be impractical for
him and his comfort zone he demanded
that his suit be replaced with cgi a
very expensive option that producers
were trying to avoid when dealing with
such a big star and symbol of the mcu
you gotta give in when it comes to their
comfortability he's not wrong for
refusing to put on the helmet that
nearly blinded him on set like i could i
was absolutely blinded that just sounds
like a disaster waiting to happen
filmmakers gave in to downey's commands
for a few projects but once it came time
for tony stark to assemble with the
avengers they asked him one more time
put two dots here and then you can paint
it in later
number five florence pew blasted into
the hawkeye series midway through and
blessed us with her grand fashion sense
i like your best god i knew it i knew
you did it's so cool right after her big
reveal pugh's elena walked through the
big apple with a very prominent fur coat
this was not a decision made by costume
designers but of florence's own instinct
what this is crazy
and for a very odd reason pew decided
that looking like a pirate while eating
mac and cheese would just be too
hilarious to miss out on
number six oh timothy chamele you've
given us some great performances over
the years but your character's fashion
picks are just all too noticeable for us
to look away i'd like to buy these
sunglasses we get a couple scenes with
chameleon and netflix's don't look up a
movie that pulls the midwest out of his
character through his wardrobe and him
not wanting to wear the same clothes
from previous films he had an idea he
thought his character would fit better
in a mullet well
kind of obsessed over it
number 7 we know this one will be a fan
favorite we're showing you samuel
jackson's argument over his lightsaber
but we won't force his opinion on you
i'm like the second baddest jedi in the
universe
jackson had a verbal duel with star wars
director george lucas over his
lightsaber color lucas refused and said
mace windu would not like any jedi or
sith have a purple colored lightsaber
samuel thought it would bring out
windu's image in the clone wars to let
his characters stand out so i could find
myself in that big fight scene in the
middle of that you know but windu's
knowledge of the force was extensive and
who's to say he didn't play a little
jedi mind trick on him to finally give
in
number 8 emma watson has proved to us
time and time again of her heroicness
and this time she made a statement that
everyone needed to hear about belle
she's a lesson in persistence and grit
for her role in disney's beauty and the
beast her character's wardrobe was
modeled after the original cartoon but
slim waists and tight corsets were not a
part of the way she wanted to embody the
role so she had costume designers make a
few changes to her outfits we went
through a long design process where we
tried different looks with her concerns
over portraying unhealthy images of the
body and just really needing to move
during scenes filmmakers were more than
happy to oblige
number nine bryce dallas howard's
wardrobe change during jurassic world is
yet another reason why actors and
actresses need to comfortably move
around of course it's illogical for her
to be in heels in the jungle she caused
shock waves in cinemas for running away
from hungry dinosaurs in high heels she
showed skill doing so but this was no
sacrifice for her she was given the
choice by filmmakers to either wear
heels or no shoes at all sequel riders
actually rode out the heels and gave her
some comfy shoes instead dallas
soulfully agreed
no heels 2018. and i was like yeah boy
number 10 cobra kai would be nothing
without the legendary johnny lawrence
and william zapka's love for the rock
tease
you like speedwagon what kind of man
doesn't zapka had a big issue with some
of the t-shirts he was given from
costume designer frank helmer they
didn't match any of the bands his
character would like this authentic and
limited selection was tough to find but
helmer demanded that they would not be
used in every scene
number 11 hbo's euphoria is known to
have some of the best outfits for its
characters hunter schaefer plays jules
on the show and oh does she know how to
pick cool outfits thank you don't really
feel it but you know
it doesn't hurt that shaper is a
professional model making her an
excellent choice to consult about her
wardrobe costume designer heidi bivens
explained how the process worked she had
very specific ideas about what could
work for jules so she would dm me any
ideas and i picked up the ball and ran
with it number 12 it wasn't only shaffer
that bivens entrusted with wardrobe
choices star of the show zoe zendaya was
always allowed to have input on her
costumes we'll all get a little boy's
tux
so that's what we did she not only gave
her opinion on her character's look but
zendaya gave bittens the suggestion to
have roo wear little boy hanes tops in
episode 7. roo would never care about
what she wore so this pretty much worked
with the scene as a whole i feel amazing
number 13 alright now we're heading back
to harry potter it's ivana lynch's turn
first you had your own ideas about what
you wanted to wear lynch worked on that
iconic headdress from harry potter and
the half blood prince on her own at the
bequest of costume designer janie tamim
she wanted to take full control of
luna's awesome bizarreness in the most
lunar way possible if it was not for
luna you will have made it better than
that
perhaps
number 14. even alan rickman hopped on
the costume change drain having demanded
that his costume be the most fitting for
his character i said the sleeves should
be really tight and there should be a
lot of buttons the many buttons and
tight sleeves rickman wanted for snape
was quite possibly a weird request for
the wardrobe department
yes
he was very involved in the costumes for
his character but it really did work out
in the end and gave a much needed break
for the costume designers
number 15 this instance of a costume
change was actually definitely needed a
young daniel ratcliffe underwent a
pretty painful experience for this one
i'm over it now we all know jk rowling
had a very big say in what was done in
the harry potter films so even the
little details had to be included that
meant harry's eyes had to be green so
contacts were the only solution the only
really important thing is that his eyes
look like his mother's eyes
unfortunately for him they were
extremely painful however filmmakers
decided in the end that it was best to
just throw out the lenses
number 16 tom hiddleston wasn't much of
a costume changer during his time on
loki he doesn't even have his clothes or
his magical powers the initial idea was
to have loki in his original costumes
from avengers but tom had different
ideas he wanted to blend his character
in with that 50s tva style it sort of is
a mirror for himself
number 17 our last harry potter actress
was actually very involved with her
costume and it seems designers had big
trust in her for her character's looks
bonnie wright had many accessories in
mind for ginny her mother was a jeweler
so it probably saved production on
additional expenses
number 18 jason bateman is just a
different actor always wearing the same
shoes it's just he's just like like a
nice old pair of shoes
this one is so slight that we may not
have even seen it had it not been in
every project he's worked on bateman's
signature new balance sneakers can be
spotted everywhere he goes and we're
sure he has to demand that they be a
part of his wardrobe every time
number 19 timothy really shows us time
and time again that he can dress to
impress not expecting that very random
but thank you great style once he was
cast in little women he was basically
entrusted with putting his clothes
together for the day could we maybe see
him working in the wardrobe department
someday
number 20. we remember binge watching
netflix's queen's gambit and the loving
every second that anya taylor joy was on
screen
her outfits changed over the course of
the mini series a change that was guided
by joy herself for beth's character it
became a ping pong relationship between
her and the costume designer seeing how
these artists work together and
tailoring their own outfits was
definitely interesting we never knew
that an actor really ever had any say in
the costuming process
did you disagree with any of the final
costuming decisions
leave a comment below